[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
various news outlets are telling us that
the mueller report is finally on its way
we have no inside information about that
though we should say that apparently the
white house believes it too when
motorsport
does arrive it will go first to the
attorney general and the deputy attorney
general and there's not much debate
about what should happen
after that democrats have demanded the
release of the entire document
the president agrees with them he said
he'd like to see that report go public
so that voters can assess it for
themselves of course we'll bring it all
to you
when that happens but for now we'd like
to take just a second to put this entire
sprawling story into some perspective
our job on this show
is to remember things to create a record
of what has happened
in this country over the past few years
and what has happened to it
our grandchildren will want to know if
the left has its way they will never see
the details
it will all be whitewashed like so much
else in our history has been
so let's recall for the record what the
robert mueller investigation
is all about we got a special counsel in
the first place
the point was not to discover whether
the president fudged deductions on his
tax returns 30 years ago
it was not to find out whether he wanted
to build another hotel in a foreign
country
from its first day the mueller
investigation was justified by a single
question
did donald trump collude with the
russian government to steal the 2016
presidential election
did the president betray his country
for close to three years democrats have
told us that yes he did do that
it's beyond the shadow of a doubt to me
that
if there was not collusion there was at
least the effort to collude
i think there's plenty of evidence of
collusion or conspiracy in plain sight
there's more to be learned about it i
believe there's been collusion
it's starting to smell more and more
like collusion
we saw cold hard evidence
of the trump campaign indeed the trump
family
eagerly intending to collude possibly
with russia these are not minor charges
and if you grew up in this country it is
hard to shrug them off
now maxine waters is irrelevant she's a
living sideshow
but nancy pelosi is not she is the
speaker of the house of representatives
she's third in line to the presidency
adam schiff is the chairman of the house
intelligence committee he's privy to the
most highly classified information
our government has john podesta who you
just saw was the chief of staff
in one white house he was a senior
advisor in another white house
beta o'rourke has raised more money than
anyone running for president
in 2020. these are not peripheral
figures making these charges
they're the most serious people in the
modern democratic party
and we took them seriously we felt we
had a duty to understand why they were
calling the president of the united
states
a traitor so we asked them we
interviewed a number of those people on
this show
one of the most persistent accusers was
congressman eric swalwell of california
he's also a member of the house
intelligence committee
if there was indeed evidence of
collusion with russia eric swalwell
would have seen it
yet he never produced any and we asked
him repeatedly swell responded by
accusing us
of cutting him off on the air not
letting him make his case
so finally in frustration we offered him
a full half hour live on this show
to tell us what the evidence was
if you have any evidence at all of
collusion any and i don't care how small
it is
i will give the floor to you and i mean
that because i just i want to wrap this
up i'm sure you do too
so months later swallow accepted our
invitation he came on the show but he
never produced a single piece of
evidence that the trump campaign
colluded with anyone
instead he accused us of working for a
foreign power
we'd ask why the public couldn't see a
memo related to the russia investigation
here's how he responded in the case of
today's memo
what specifically have i espoused
that empowers threats to our country
you're peddling the narrative that the
trump administration is putting out
which also is the putin
narrative because they're retweeting
this with their russian bots this
if you're on the same side as wikileaks
and i wonder do you person
you're on the same side as wikileaks and
putin you should take a step back and
wonder
who's bidding are you really doing
so for asking to see a government
document that he himself had seen
congressman eric swalwell suggested that
we were treasonous
there's been an awful lot of talk like
that over the past couple of years it
has completely changed washington
people in this city are now afraid they
watch what they say they don't send
emails
they worry about being denounced
demagogues like swawa have terrified
them
from the beginning of this investigation
there has been virtually no honest
public debate about what is happening or
what has happened
watch this exchange from the early days
of the administration congressman adam
schiff came on this show we asked a
simple fact-based question
about what we know and what we don't
know and it was are we certain the
russian government hacked
john podesta's gmail account here's how
adam schiff responded
can you look right into the camera and
say i know for a fact the government of
vladimir putin was behind the hacks
of john podesta absolutely the
government of vladimir putin was behind
the hacks of our institution and the
dumping
of john podesta's not only in the united
states
but also in europe okay you're not you
know what you're dodging
and tucker look and say i know they did
john pedesta
i think that uh ronald reagan is rolling
over ronald reagan ronald reagan
you're carrying water for the kremlin
carrying water from this i'm not
you're making you look you're a city
member of congress on the intel
committee and you can't say
they hocked you're gonna you're gonna
have to move your shoulder to rt
russian television
so to this day even the most basic the
most elemental questions about the
claims in this russia story remain
unanswered meanwhile we've upended our
entire
foreign policy we put americans in
prison all on the basis of charges
nobody has been willing to prove how do
we know that congressman
shut up you're a russian agent the
conspiracy hawks seemed
totally impervious to shame or reason
you couldn't debate them
because they wouldn't engage they just
threw slurs they felt no need to
demonstrate that any of it was true
at what point do you draw the line and
not accuse the president united states
without any evidence of being an agent
of russia yeah
he's betrayed our country and i don't i
don't say that lightly i worked as a
prosecutor for seven years and i
train the country by the way we want
evidence before you say that but
you said an agent of russia yeah he he
works on their behalf but as a
prosecutor that wouldn't be evidence in
court i mean as a prosecutor
you know the difference between hard
evidence and circumstantial evidence i'm
not hearing the evidence that he's an
agent of russia
yeah i i think it's pretty clear it's
almost hiding in plain sight
it wasn't just swolwell and schiff some
of the most respected supposedly sober
figures in our society engaged in this
behavior for
years they said things that were so
reckless and so damaging to this country
that it's almost hard to believe it was
happening
keep in mind as you watch this clip that
not so long ago john brennan was the
director of the cia
the most powerful intelligence agency in
the world
mcclatchy is reporting right now that
special counsel robert mueller has
evidence
that trump's personal lawyer and fixer
michael cohen secretly made a late
summer trip to prague during the 2016
presidential campaign according to two
sources familiar with the matter
confirmation
the trip would confirm from part of the
steele dossier reports that uh
mr cohen was in prague despite his
denials repeated denials uh
there is more and more uh indications
that uh
there is something here that is
far far from being anything near a witch
hunt
michael cohen was in prague meeting with
his russian handlers that's what brennan
just told us on cable television
now you'd think if anyone would know
that fact it would be the director of
the cia the cia
knows all except perhaps on this one
question michael cohen himself
might know more cohen was asked directly
about it when he testified before
congress cohen had no reason to protect
donald trump
he had many reasons to hurt him here's
what cohen said
you have been to prague i've never been
to prague never have i've never been to
the czech republic
yeah i balanced my time at the same
hearing
cohen also told congress that in all his
years working as donald trump's personal
attorney
one of the most intimate relationships
in donald trump's life he had never seen
any evidence of collusion with russia
now any fair person would consider that
the beginning of the end of this story
case closed
but it was too late by that point the
russia investigation had become
such a ratings bonanza for the cable
news channels that they couldn't slow
down
they had no incentive to admit defeat
they had no incentive to acknowledge
reality
so they continued as they had since the
inauguration as if the story was
entirely real
night after night they brought us an
endless parade of screamers buffoons and
half wits
all claiming knowledge of the conspiracy
here to pick one among
a thousand examples is self-described
intelligence expert malcolm nance
delivering his analysis on msnbc
when benedict arnold gave the plans to
west point to major andre
and they captured major andre they did
not have
any real information linking those plans
to benedict arnold
other than the fact that he was in his
presence at one point during that day
but everyone knew it was treason when
they caught the man
and they hung him so at some point there
is going to be a bridge of data here
that is going to be unassailable
thanks for the history lesson mr nance
they hung him let's hang this guy
and after a while after years of this
voters started to agree
thanks to propaganda like what you just
saw 53 percent of registered voters now
believe
the trump campaign quote worked with
russia to influence the 2016 election
among democratic voters fully 67
believe that russia somehow rigged the
vote tally
nobody's ever explained how exactly the
russians might have done that
but of course they did it russia rigged
the election cnn says so every night
there need to be consequences for this
once the mueller report appears and it
becomes incontrovertible that whatever
his faults donald trump did not collude
with the russians
the many people who persistently claimed
on the basis of no evidence that he did
collude with the russians
ought to be punished not indicted or
imprisoned obviously
but thoroughly shamed and forced to
apologize
if republicans spent three full years
falsely claiming that barack obama
colluded with the government of iran
would those who claim that ever work in
media or politics again
that's a rhetorical question lying in
recklessness should never be ignored
in 2003 the united states invaded iraq
on the premise that saddam hussein
possessed
massive stockpiles of chemical and
biological weapons
many of us believed it but the claim was
false
thousands of americans died trillions
were wasted
nobody was punished to this day max boot
takes a paycheck from the washington
post
bill crystal appears on msnbc john
bolton is this country's national
security adviser
there were no consequences to their
foolishness and their dishonesty
none and so we started a series of
eerily similar wars
all with entirely predictable results
nobody learned
anything we learn anything from the
russia collusion hoax
or the same cast of liars and buffoons
simply move on to the next scam
climate change the great new deal we
can't give you details it's too
important obey or else
that could easily happen in fact it will
happen
for certain unless we remember exactly
what we've just seen